if you've ever had a conversation
with a lip about gun control
if you've ever been kind of a live
yourself
which some of us have gone through more
lib faces of Our Lives okay there but
for the grace of God go we
may have heard this argument I'll say
why did that private citizen who was
protecting himself and his family in his
property against a criminal why did he
have to shoot the criminal in the chest
why couldn't he just shoot the criminal
in the leg and that way the criminal
could live maybe
and he would still be able to stop the
bad guy
why did the cops those terrible awful
cops why when they were in a shootout
with a Criminal why didn't they just
shoot him in his ankle and that way they
could stop the bad guy maybe and he
wouldn't have to die Joy Behar just
raised this question on The View
for the for the
somebody that I can't just shoot them in
the leg why do you have to shoot them at
the house actually having dated a
homicide detective he used to tell me
when he hears that on TV his eyes roll
because you have to shoot when you're
trained with a weapon for the mass of
the body so to shoot a leg or a wrist
happens in a James Bond film but in real
life that's actually not something that
they can do why because it's hard enough
to hit a Target so when you're shot you
you target practice on a mass which is
the main part of your body your torso so
if it's hard to hit a Target why do
these gun toters want us to constantly
have guns when we're not trained to even
shoot as well as a police officer so she
tries to save her stupid questions well
then why does it why why do they want us
to have guns if we're completely
untrained
I don't want you to have a gun if you
don't know how to use it
that's a straw man I certainly don't
want people who are completely ignorant
about what Firearms do and how to use
them I do not want any of you to have a
firearm for your own sake as much as for
the rest of us because if you don't know
how to use a firearm it's probably not
going to work out well for you
if you don't know how to
hold a firearm if you don't know how to
use it when there's a bad guy
approaching most likely the bad guy's
just going to take it from you and use
it on you
so we don't we want people to be
responsible and trained and be
knowledgeable about these things that
they're using this is the consequence of
ignorance
very often the people who are the
loudest activists very often the people
in office who are regulating
all of these rights and instruments in
our society they don't even understand
the mechanics of the things that they're
regulating
right now go to helixsleep.com Knowles
with everything going on in the world
right now you could really use a good
night's sleep
that's why you got to check out Helix
mattress he likes his harness years of
extensive mattress expertise to bring
their customers a truly elevated sleep
experience
they just launched their new Helix Elite
the Helix Elite collection includes six
different mattress models
each tailored for specific sleep
positions and firmness preferences I've
had my Helix for three years now
probably and I absolutely love it night
after night I sleep like a sweet baby
and I want the same for you elix has a
sleep quiz that matches your body type
and sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress because why would you buy a
mattress made for someone else okay you
want to be in my mattress I'm a married
man get out of my Boudoir go to
helixsleep.com Knowles take their
two-minute sleep quiz to find the
perfect mattress for your body and sleep
type their flexible payment plans make
it so that a great night's sleep is
never far away Helix is offering 20 off
all mattress orders and two free pillows
for our listeners hurry on over to
helixsleep.com Knowles with Helix better
sleep starts now right now go to
cinch.com use promo code Knowles the
weather is warming up over here in
Nashville which means that we are
gearing up for backyard barbecues and
campfires the last thing you need to be
doing when you're getting ready to host
a barbecue is driving around worrying
about where to refill your propane grill
tank that is why you got to check out
cinch cinch is a propane grill tank Home
Delivery Service they deliver propane
grill tanks right to your door cinch
delivers on your schedule requires no
long-term commitment or subscription
plus delivery is completely contactless
you don't have to wait around at home
track the order on the Cinch app from
anywhere whether you're grilling steaks
or firing up the patio heaters on a cold
night cinch's propane delivery service
ensures that you have the fuel you need
to make the most of every moment go
online to cinch.com or download the
Cinch app to order new customers can get
their first tank exchange for just ten
dollars with promo code Knowles kwles
that is cinch.com or download the Cinch
app use promo code Knowles kwles to get
your first tank exchange for just ten
dollars it's a limited time offer you
must live within the Cinch service area
to redeem it visit cinch
c-ynch.com offer for details not only do
they not understand the philosophy of
why we have a second amendment of why we
have a right to protect ourselves of
what where that comes from what that
means they don't even understand how the
pew pew thing works they don't even know
what the trigger does they don't know
what it's like they're understanding as
that woman on The View said their
understanding of shooting a gun comes
from James Bond movies oh well why did
the cops have to have to stand there
and shoot the guy in the chest why
didn't they just run up jump sideways
hold the gun sideways and and shoot the
gun out of the other bad guy's hand you
know come on I saw that in a movie Once
why can't they just do that
these people have never been to a gun
range they've probably never held a gun
in their lives and this is true Beyond
gun policy this is true at all levels of
politics
the people who are doing the regulating
increasingly don't understand anything
about what they are regulating
the people who are who are passing laws
about abortion
the left Wingers passing laws about
abortion
increasingly they don't have children so
they physically don't understand what
it's like to have a baby
they often have not become pregnant
it's kind of like an inversion of the
libs argument if you're a man you
shouldn't be able to have an opinion
about abortion well okay it's the same
true of a childless woman
it's the same true of a single woman who
doesn't want to
that well that's one aspect of knowledge
but then there are more important
degrees of knowledge I don't need to
have cancer to learn something about
cancer a doctor doesn't need to have
cancer to know how to treat cancer
I don't need to have committed a murder
to know how to pass a law against murder
I don't need to have been a cop to pass
a law against murder
what is required though is some basic
understanding of morality ethics
philosophy
theology ultimately
you need to know these things in order
to be a Statesman you should have a
serious education in all of these
subjects you should be able to
understand
what the law even is
not just the positive law that we all
pass and we vote upon the Bill on
Capitol Hill but what the law even means
is the law merely an imposition of my
will because I want such and such to be
so in society or is the law primarily a
matter of interpretation that there is
such a thing as the natural law that
there are Eternal principles of justice
and and there there is an objective
moral order and we can perceive this and
and interpret this and then through a
process of translation translate the
Eternal moral order into the positive
law in the civil law and all the rest of
it is that of course that's what law is
well okay that means we need to know
something about ethics and morality well
what is more where do we get our Notions
of good and bad from
how can we know anything at all
the people passing our laws increasingly
don't know anything
about that
did you adore that clip me too if you
want to get more of them if you want to
get long interviews if you want to get
the yes or no game if you want Michael
and if you want The Daily Show subscribe
right here ring that Bell we'll see you
next time